[Music]
so I wanted to take a quick survey of
the room how many folks in the room are
game developers that work for a studio
or a publisher okay awesome
how many folks are thinking about
building their first game and need to
know more about how to scale it up in
the cloud
all right great and how many folks are
just here because games are awesome
yes all right well we're gonna have a
little bit of fun this afternoon
obviously this is a great topic and
we've got some cool stuff to share with
you so we're gonna be talking a lot
about Game Servers but before we get
into Game Servers we're gonna talk about
Google clouds mission for games so we're
gonna go a little broader about what
we're focusing on for bringing
multiplayer games to life in the cloud
then we'll get into Game Servers what
are they and why do I need them for a
game what are the metrics that matter
for running game servers well
particularly in the cloud and then how
do we scale game servers up for global
audiences how do we build really massive
games with game servers and then if you
were a GDC you might have noticed an
interesting announcement we made there
we're gonna talk a little bit about the
future of gaming in the cloud at the end
of this talk so we're very passionate
about games at Google we have a lot of
ways to work with with game developers
with game players and with creators
we're passionate about helping you
create connect and scale your games in a
lot of different ways across many
different channels today we're gonna
focus on two of those logos the second
and the third from the left we're going
to talk about Google cloud for running
your game servers and your back-end
services and we're also going to talk a
little bit about stadia so Google clouds
mission for games so as it turns out
building and scaling a global
multiplayer game has quite a bit of
complexity involved in it right and if
there's two things that Google is really
good at its scaling things up really big
we currently have eight services that
have a billion user
in them each daily so Google really
focuses on scaling and we also focus on
reducing complexity the reason that
services like Gmail and YouTube and Docs
became so popular is because we were
able to take the complexity out of using
those services so we want to bring that
same sensibility to games we want to
scale games up really big and we want to
make it as easy as possible for you to
do that so we have four pillars that we
believe will help us deliver on our
mission number one cross platform cross
platform and cross play have become
really important concepts recently with
games right players want to be able to
enjoy a game on a device of their
choosing game servers are a critical
component in delivering cross platform
and cross play experiences Google is a
leader in open source so with kubernetes
we established a de-facto open standard
for interacting with infrastructure in
the cloud kubernetes is your open source
API to compute and storage running in
any cloud or in your own data centers we
want to bring that same sensibility to
games so for any of the game services
that we're building we're gonna go open
source because we believe you should be
able to run them anywhere this is in
stark contrast to the gaming services
that you might find in other clouds
which tend to be proprietary and involve
a degree of lock-in so Google also has a
lot of expertise in machine learning and
analytics and we're very excited about
bringing our capabilities to bear for
games in this space as well and I think
that first slide that we looked at does
a really nice job of discussing that one
Google story we have a lot of different
ways to help build and publish amazing
games and we're gonna explore one Google
a little bit more when we talk about GCP
and stadia later on so what is our cloud
for games team building
we're focusing on three different areas
first is game server hosting we're
focused on making our compute platform
the best and most high-performance place
to run your games this is going to be
the focus of our talk today but to run a
large multiplayer game you'll also need
platform services you need a place to
run your API so that your users can log
in and get assigned to a match so we're
doing work there and we're also bringing
the scale of our analytics and machine
learning solutions to gaming as well so
we're gonna focus mostly on game servers
for today but we're working in all three
of those areas so this is our reference
architecture for games
so most games have a fairly similar flow
when it's a multiplayer experience so a
gamer starts by logging into their
profile loading up their attributes
their skill level other items that'll be
used later on in their play experience
that's step one that's a platform
service API call step two once I'm
signed in I need to find some friends to
play a game with that's called
matchmaking so I make a call to a
matchmaker service I get assigned to a
match with a bunch of my friends and
next up we need to play a game we need
to get assigned into a match so the
third step in the process is that this
group of people who've been assigned
together into a match get assigned to a
game server and then finally as we're
interacting together in that game lots
of interesting events are being
generated so we want to capture those
events in a data warehouse so that you
can analyze what your players are doing
think about how to improve the customer
experience and how to monetize your game
most effectively okay so in today's talk
we're gonna focus mostly on this part of
the equation the game servers so let's
start by defining what game servers are
so that we have a common language for
discussion
so what are Game Servers and why do I
need them for my multiplayer game so
we'll start with sort of the definition
and then we'll dig in a little bit
deeper but a game server is the
authoritative source of events for your
game a game server broadcasts that state
to all of the clients so that they can
visualize an accurate representation of
what that player should be seeing the
game server also captures and processes
all of the inputs from your player and
the game server needs to do this on a
very consistent and timely manner in
order to provide a smooth and fluid
experience to your players so let's use
an example one of my favorite games apex
Legends who loves apex Legends awesome
let's use Apex Legends as an example so
to understand what a game server does we
need to also understand what a game
client does and how the client and the
server interact with one another so on
the left hand side you can see a picture
of what a game client does a game client
so let's take a match of Apex legends 60
players battle royale format right you
have 60 game clients one for each player
they're gonna be running on a PC or a
console or for some games they might be
running on a mobile device the
responsibilities of a game client is to
render the graphical experience that
that player is experiencing graphics
sound and input are the primary
responsibilities of the client because
this is a graphically intensive workload
this is where your GPU comes into play
so a game client is heavily reliant on a
GPU to get this job done
so if graphics are what game client
focuses on and for if it's for one
player and what does a game server do
well game server is running in a data
center on a host or a virtual machine
that's the first difference all of the
players that got assigned into that
match all sixty players their game
clients are going to connect to that
game server
the game server contrary to what you
might believe doesn't process graphics
at all
the game server is responsible for the
state of that game world and because the
game server is dealing with data rather
than graphics this is a CPU intensive
process you don't typically have a GPU
involved in a game server at all so an
analogy that I like to use is a game
server you know for this island that 60
players are dropping onto that the game
server is sort of penciling in the
details of that world and drawing out a
blueprint and then that blueprint is
sent out to the game clients where a
high fidelity graphic representation of
what that player sees is rendered based
on that blueprint that's generated by
the server so let's talk a little bit
more specifically about what game
servers do game servers have to receive
the input from the players based on that
input game servers are gonna track the
positions of those players on the map
those game players are going to interact
with obstacles they're gonna run into
buildings they might even run into each
other the game server is gonna process
what's happening when those objects
collide we have physics like gravity in
combat games you're gonna have particles
flying around so the game server is
calculating velocities and hits or
misses and so once all those
calculations are performed the game
server is broadcasting the results back
out to those game clients so they can
render the results and this has to
happen very consistently up to 120 times
a second in very high fidelity games so
let's go back to our example of Apex
legends and let's talk through what's
actually happening as we're playing
through that game of Apex so these
battle royale games all start in about
the same way you've got a Big Island and
airship passes over the island
and those 60 players begin to skydive
one by one onto that island falling at
terminal velocity 160 miles an hour to
their preferred destinations on that map
the game server is
calculating the positions of all those
players as they're falling to the ground
now this players are adjusting their
body position which changes wind
resistance velocity trajectory
acceleration all of these things are
being recalculated in real time by that
game server so next those players land
on the island they begin picking up loot
they begin picking up items weapons
preparing for the battle ahead the game
server is keeping track of each player's
inventory and the position of objects on
the island players start going upstairs
entering buildings running into walls
now we're doing collision detection and
once all the players have equipped
themselves sufficiently the combat
begins projectiles start flying around
hits and misses are calculated if we
have explosive projectiles we have
particles that are being generated all
of this is being calculated by the game
server and at the beginning of the match
we start with 60 players and as the
match goes on we get down to one player
the ultimate victor in the game right
and so what you might realize is at the
beginning of the match
there's a whole lot of work that that
game server has to do to calculate all
60 players inputs and positions at the
end of the game there's a lot less work
to do but regardless of sort of that
changing workload the game server has to
maintain a constant tick rate throughout
the match so you might say okay you know
I've been playing multiplayer games for
a while what do we need game servers for
we used to have this thing called
peer-to-peer in a peer-to-peer model
you've got let's say we've got a few pcs
that have been assigned to a match
together and we sort of elect one of
them to also take on the role of the
game server so that PC will become not
only the game client but also the game
server well so there are a few problems
with this approach number one your game
your pcs are located on a home network
and there's lots of variables out in
that environment how do we pick which
one of these pcs should become the
server
we pick the highest clockspeed should we
pick the lowest latency or the best
bandwidth let's say that we go with the
best network connection now after the
match starts let's say someone else in
that house starts streaming a 4k video
or let's say that someone in that house
starts downloading a huge file and a
peer-to-peer network all of a sudden the
network characteristics of that PC have
fundamentally changed let's talk about
scale
today's battle royale games have fifty
sixty a hundred players a few network
connections into a consumer network that
scales just fine let's try a hundred
connections into a PC on a home network
it doesn't scale and finally in the mode
probably the most significant issue is
that remember we said that server needs
to be authoritative right so if that
binary is deployed onto someone's PC
they can hack that binary they can mess
with the authoritative nature of that
game server all of the traffic from all
of those players is coming in to that
person's home network they can interfere
with that traffic to change the balance
of the game in their own favor
so peer-to-peer was great when we got
started but for the types of high
fidelity experiences people want today
we've outgrown peer to peer so how are
dedicated servers different we've got
one additional component that we bring
into play which is that we make that we
deploy that game server into a virtual
machine in a professional data center
what does this do for us it brings us
additional consistency now my network is
being managed by professionals it's
being monitored by sres
I don't have the kinds of issues that I
have on a home network
I have high-speed network interconnects
on these virtual machines so I can scale
up to more connections per game server
and most important of all that binary is
firewalled
in a professional environment it's much
harder to interfere with that binary and
with the network traffic going into that
data center
so now we're ready for a world class
multiplayer experience okay so we
understand what game servers are and why
we need them to deliver world-class
experiences what matters for game
servers we need to understand this to be
able to deliver the type of services
that high fidelity games demand
performance matters and there's two key
metrics for a game server the first is
latency this is a network metric so if
we have game clients that are
communicating multiple times per second
with that server and need to receive
replies back multiple times per second
we need the lowest possible network
latency between those clients and that
server so that's our network benchmark
and then if we're running on our game
server in a tight loop that's processing
all of those events that I told you
about for up to a hundred players and a
match our CPU needs to be able to
process that loop consistently so we
call that frame time so that's our CPU
performance metric we're gonna dig into
both of these a little bit more because
these are really important so let's talk
latency what kind of latency do we need
for a real-time game generally speaking
for a real-time game like an apex
Legends
you're gonna want about 25 milliseconds
round-trip time to your clients or less
that's preferred some games you might be
able to get away with higher latency 50
milliseconds maybe a hundred
milliseconds it's going to depend on the
game but for the types of games we're
talking about 25 milliseconds or less is
preferred so let's look at a map of the
United States let's say that we're
running our game server on one coast and
we're running a client on another coast
you got at least 50 milliseconds
typically between those two endpoints so
we've already doubled our latency goal
that's not gonna work
well if I'm looking at these at this map
and I'm familiar with GCP I might say
you know those little blue flags those
are Google Data Centers I'm gonna be
clever and I'm gonna put all my game
servers and that one right in the middle
well networks are funny things you might
expect the latency to cut in half but
it's not always a function just a
distance it can be carrier it can be
carrier based and there can be other
there can be other concerns like the
number of hops between the two endpoints
so deploying all of your game servers on
a continental basis generally is not
going to hit the mark
so you're typically going to end up with
something that looks like this where you
deploy collections of game servers to
several different data centers and then
you assign players in a radius around
those data centers to the closest
possible deployment there's a bit of an
art to this right because as you shrink
those circles you start decreasing the
number of people that can play a game
together
so if you shrink those circles to small
your matchmaking pool becomes too small
and people can't find other players to
play with but if it gets too big your
latency is too high so there's a bit of
an art to sort of balancing those two
things and sort of helping you figure
out how to deploy your game servers
based on your audience is something that
we can help with
so that's latency now let's talk about
our CPU benchmark frame rates and
budgets now again imagine in a sort of a
simplified model of a game server that
you just have a while loop that's
running and all of those things that I
told you about are sort of a line item
in that while loop you're going to want
to go through that each tick of that
while loop in exactly the same amount of
time every single frame so we call it a
tick rate sometimes it's also called a
frame rate and so for a battle royale
game
a typical tick rate might be 20 to 30
ticks per second 20 to 30 Hertz so
that's exactly the frequency that you
want to iterate through that loop so if
you have a tick rate of 20 Hertz you've
got about 50 milliseconds to
make it through a single pass of that
game servers main loop 50 milliseconds
may sound like a lot of time but let's
take into consideration how many players
we've gotten that match we have 60
players so per player I've less than one
millisecond to get through that main
loop one to two milliseconds is a big
deal on a game server so there's not a
lot of room for variance and we'll talk
more about variants in a little bit so
let's zoom in on what's happening during
those frames okay this is two frames
being processed on a game server we're
going with that 20 Hertz tick rate we
have 50 milliseconds to get through a
single frame in this example we're
actually able to get all of our work
done in 40 milliseconds that's great we
got done early but remember we have to
wake up for the next frame right on the
boundary of 50 milliseconds so we're
gonna go to sleep for 10 for 10
milliseconds then we wake up and start
processing the next frame this is what
we want to see frame after frame after
frame we finish within budget and maybe
a little bit left over to account for
variance this is what we don't want to
see so in this example still 50
millisecond frame budget it took me 60
milliseconds to process that frame now
I'm into the next frame what am I going
to do here I'm gonna have to drop that
second frame so all of my clients are
not going to receive an update for that
frame so let's think about what this
looks like over time the top scenario is
what we want to see we want to see every
single one of those frames consistently
processed because when this happens all
of our players are gonna have a very
fluid very consistent experience that
game is gonna flow just like a movie
that they're watching that's what we
want in the bottom example or dropping
frames pretty frequently what that's
going to result in is what we call
rubber banding stuttering you're going
to see skipping around in the game and
after
maybe a few minutes of that you're gonna
have some very unhappy players that are
gonna start logging tickets not good so
let's be a little bit more specific what
do we mean when we say consistent for
most games we want to process those
frames within budget at least 95 percent
of the time if not higher so we need a
very very high level of consistency and
a very low level of variance so one of
the things that I'm very excited to talk
about today is our compute platform okay
clouds are busy places running a game in
the cloud is very different than running
a game on a bare-metal server we have a
hypervisor on that cloud scheduling
resources that has overhead associated
with it and you have other tenants that
are running processes on that same host
they may be running game servers also
those two things can introduce
significant variants into the
performance that you're encountering on
a game server okay so up until today
we've had one type of virtual machine if
you've used GCP you're very familiar
with n1 standard virtual machines
they're really cool we abstract all of
the underlying Hardware away and what
that means is I can go in there and dial
in exactly how many V CPUs I want from 1
to 96 I can dial in exactly how much RAM
I want very customizable very flexible
but in order to accomplish that very
abstracted from the underlying hardware
also our n1 standards on skylake which
is our newest our newest generation of
of hardware up until today runs at 2.7
gigahertz
that's our sustained clock speed across
all cores so today we're introducing an
entirely new hardware platform called
compute optimized VMs and these are
going to bump the clock speed up
significantly to 3.8 gigahertz and
that's sustained across
all all cores and we've also got some
features in there that are going to
reduce the variance that you're gonna
see even at that high clock speed so
let's dig in a little bit so compared to
our sky lakes running on n ones you're
going to see a 40% increase in
performance on our computer optimized
VMs what does that mean
conceptually that processing time in
your main loop could decrease by 40
percent you get a lot more room for
error
you can also do a lot more with in that
same 50 milliseconds we've also
increased the speed of the network up to
32 gigabits per second now I can think
about connecting more players to my game
server because I've got more clock
cycles and I've got more throughput on
the network so that's high performance
let's talk about variants so I've
Illustrated a physical host here this is
sort of a conceptual version of what a
host and the cloud looks like we have
very large CPUs typically more than one
socket running on a host those sockets
are connected with an interconnect and
they each have a local ram bus right in
an n1 standard that that's all
abstracted away from you you just have a
big bucket of cores and a big bucket of
RAM right let's say that you're running
a game on the CPU on the left and some
of your ram has been scheduled onto the
ram bank for the other socket I'm gonna
have to reach across that interconnect
to access my RAM which is gonna be a lot
slower than if I were to access that
same Ram locally and I don't have any
visibility or control into that on a
standard VM in a lot of cases that's
still fine for your game but for cases
that are very sensitive to performance
with our compute optimized VMs we're
exposing the underlying hardware
platform which is cascade Lake so now
you'll be able to have transparency into
the physical hardware that's running on
the host and we're also accessing we're
also exposing this topology so now you
have visibility into the Numa topology
of the host
so it gives you a lot more control over
the workload that you're running we also
do some cool things like pinning your
RAM to the local socket so if you run
the right size shape you can effectively
capture that socket and your RAM will be
pinned to that local Ram node so some
really cool stuff for gaming with
compute optimized VMs those go into
alpha today I've got my contact
information on the last slide and if
you're interested in starting to test
them reach out to me and I'll help you
get that set up all right let's talk
about scaling up so now we know what's
needed to run a game server we want to
run a whole lot of game servers so how
do we scale the game server up for
global audiences so in the picture of
the United States you saw a few
different GCP regions globally we have
19 regions we have four more coming
that'll be 23 regions so those are
different locations that you can place
your virtual machines as close as
possible to the gamers that we'll be
connecting to them so this picture might
look like a lot like the picture that
you see from other clouds right all
clouds have regions we all have zones
one of the fundamental differences
between our cloud and other clouds is
that all of our regions and all of our
edge pops are connected together with
our private fiber optic interconnect so
in other clouds when you're transiting
between data centers or between edge
pops you're going to be transiting the
internet so you're subject to the
network topology of the internet with
Google cloud when you're transiting
between data centers and from pop to
data center it's all on our private
fiber so I mentioned we have 19 regions
that's a pretty nice selection of
locations to deploy your servers if you
look a little closer on this diagram
there's all these gray dots those are
our edge pop locations we have a hundred
and thirty-four edge
locations all with fiber interconnects
back to our data centers game servers
use public IPS that's how our game
clients out on the internet connect to
them when I spin up a virtual machine in
GCP that public IP is globally
advertised at all hundred and
thirty-four of those edge pops so when
your client goes to connect to the
region that's closest to him he's
actually gonna connect to the edge pop
that's even closer and then he's gonna
transit the fiber into our data center
so this is how we're gonna get you as
close as possible to your gamers and
give you the lowest possible latency
into those locations okay so let's talk
about scaling now that we understand we
have a global private fiber-optic
network to run our games on only with
GCP let's think about how we're gonna
scale up on the network and we've got
three different options I mentioned
earlier that Google is all about open
wheel of choice so we have three
different ways that you can run your
game servers in our cloud you can build
the scaling infrastructure yourself and
some of you have already we have an
awesome managed partner that you can
work with to help you run your game
servers and you can look into using
kubernetes and containers and leveraging
the power of kubernetes to scale so
let's talk about these three options so
let's start with building it ourselves
so let's say that we want to deploy our
game server into three different zones
we're going to use the basic fundamental
building blocks of Google cloud we're
gonna use virtual machines and the API
is associated with them and to scale the
collection of virtual machines up and
down we're gonna use managed instance
groups which will create new virtual
machines for us very easily so in each
zone we'll have a collection of VMs and
a managed instance group to scale up and
down so that's the GCP infrastructure
that we're going to use we're also going
to need some additional infrastructure
that we're going
to build which is typically called a
server manager or an auto scaler and
that piece of software is going to be
responsible for calling out to the
appropriate managed instance groups and
VMs and scaling them up and down what
sounds pretty easy you know I don't have
to depend on anyone else this actually
turns out to be a pretty complex piece
of software to write and in order to
understand why it's complex we need to
look at how game servers are deployed
but generally speaking we're gonna
recommend this option for those that
have already written this piece of
software and for their own bare metal
environments for another cloud and
simply would need to retrofit it to use
our managed instance groups and VMs so
let's look at what game servers look
like when they're deployed right do we
just spin up a whole bunch of VMs for
each one of these game servers typically
not a game server is a pretty
lightweight process it's typically
single threaded for that reason it
typically only needs a single core maybe
two cores and so there's too much
overhead and spinning up a virtual
machine for one v CPU so what's commonly
done even on bare metal is you bring up
a larger host and then you bin pack a
bunch of processes on to that host
utilizing however many cores your
particular game server needs so in this
example I've got an n1 standard 16 16 V
CPUs and I've got about about 16 game
server processes running on that single
virtual machine so when you're thinking
about scaling up and scaling down you're
not only spinning up virtual machines
but you have to worry about all that bin
packing you have to think about how to
drain that host as matches come to a
close so there's a lot of lifecycle that
needs to be built into your server
manager not to mention error handling
but for shops that have built their own
logic this can be a great route to go
we're actually very excited that the
division 2 is running with this
methodology on GCP so that game launched
on GCP very recently we're very excited
that they're running at scale in our
cloud using this methodology and what
massive really loved about working with
Google is that we understand games we're
gamers we love digging in and helping
companies scale their games up in our
cloud so that's the build-it-yourself
model and you can scale games way up if
you're willing to invest in that
infrastructure let's talk about the
manish partner option maybe you don't
want to invest all that time in building
your own scaling infrastructure and
instead you'd prefer to enlist the
expertise of a partner who's a
professional running game servers who
can provide 24/7 365 service who can run
your game servers not only in cloud but
also in a collection of bare-metal
coalos located globally a partner who
has 20 years of experience running game
servers we're very excited to work with
multi-play as our game server hosting
partner and they can provide a managed
partner level of service to you and
we're even more excited to talk about
apex Legends which uses the multi play
service on GCP to scale up for a global
audience some of these numbers are
pretty incredible so apex Legends scaled
up to a million players in 8 hours
think about that for a minute that
number seems incredible but then think
about the fact that it's scaled up to 10
million players in three days and then
multiplied that number by 5 and scaled
up to 50 million players in only 4 weeks
this is exactly the kind of outcome that
you want for your game and this is why
you would work with a partner like multi
play and run your your game on a global
cloud like GCP if you read any of the
press around the apex Legends launch it
was really positive about how smooth the
experience was for the players this game
just went from zero to Millions
without a hitch and that's because of
that combination
multi-play & GCP scalability this is a
very exciting use case so then let's
talk about the third option for scaling
game servers the third option is
leveraging the power of kubernetes so
when you think back to that diagram that
I drew earlier virtual machine with a
bunch of processes been packed on to it
that sounds an awful lot like a
kubernetes node with a bunch of
containers been packed on to it
kubernetes is really really good at
doing that however kubernetes doesn't
understand game servers kubernetes is
designed for stateless workloads it's
designed for HTTP workloads so we built
an extension to kubernetes called a go
nice with Ubisoft that teaches
kubernetes about game servers
it teaches kubernetes how to handle UDP
endpoints I teaches kubernetes about
game server life cycle so that
kubernetes doesn't decide to scale down
your game servers in the middle of a
match so with a go nice we're building
an open API to run and scale your games
with kubernetes in an environment of
your choosing and in the same way that
we approached kubernetes and gke we're
working on a managed service for agonise
as well that we'd love to talk to you
about so we're excited that supersolid
has chosen to launch their new games
snake rivals this will be the first
production game on agonise and we're
we're just thrilled to have this game
launching on agonies we're working with
many other studios on non production
games for a go NACE so you have sort of
these three different choices and you
can choose which of these is the best
fit for your team and for your game and
any of these three you're gonna know
that you've got Google's infrastructure
powering your game behind the scenes so
let's talk about the future of cloud
gaming this thing called stadia
so our client and server discussion will
come in handy here stadia is a new kind
of gaming platform it brings high
fidelity triple-a games to any screen
that can run Chrome it does that by
moving that game client that we talked
about earlier with its GPU into the
cloud rendering the content in a cloud
data center and then streaming that
content as if it was a video to a cloud
to a Chrome screen so in a sense if
we've moved the game server into the
cloud with GCP we've moved the game
client into the cloud with Stadio so
let's talk about what that private
fiber-optic network does for us with
stadia 10 - 25 milliseconds - our client
sounded pretty good
without stadia now our clients are
running on the same fibre optic network
that our servers are running on - think
about what that does to your average
latency to your clients and what kinds
of possibilities that opens up for new
types of games and new types of
interactions that haven't been possible
when your games clients were distributed
on the Internet now we mentioned that
Google is an o is open you could still
run your game servers in a Colo or in
another cloud and it'll work with stadia
but you're gonna be back to that old
latency model where you're transiting
the Internet 10 to 25 milliseconds so
we're really excited about the new types
of games that people will build when the
entire game infrastructure is on the
same private fibre optic network so
here's a bit more of a detailed view of
what the architecture would look like so
the only thing that's out on the
internet now is your Chrome device your
game client has been moved into one of
those edge pops that I showed earlier in
our network diagram
so it's even closer to your players than
the game server is but it's
communicating with your game servers
over that private fiber that you saw
earlier here's the same picture if
you're running your game servers in
another cloud or in a Colo you're still
going to get great performance but
you're not gonna get that same level of
low latency that you're gonna get with
everything running on the same network
so what a stadium GCP do together
security all of your network traffic now
is on a private fiber-optic network
except for the streaming the streaming
data going back to your clients
performance we've already talked about
let's talk a little bit about egress one
of the significant costs of running game
servers can be egress if I'm sending
updates to hundreds of players tens or
hundreds of times a second that
generates a lot of egress you have to
pay for egress in the cloud when your
egress is going from GCP to stadia we've
worked out a significant discount on the
egress so it'll be actually less
expensive to run your game servers in
GCP if they're interacting with stadia
so we're really excited about this
combination we're excited about the new
types of games that you'll build and
we're very excited to work with you to
scale those games up in the cloud so
would love your feedback on the session
my contact information is at the bottom
of the screen feel free to email me or
reach out to me on Twitter or LinkedIn
if you're interested in those compute
optimized VMs let me know I'll help you
get whitelisted we think they're gonna
be pretty awesome we've gotten some
early feedback from a major triple-a
studio and they're very very excited
about the performance that they're
seeing in their early testing
[Music]